JD expressed that he really wants to
date Katy Perry and he came to me today
he goes I wrote a love poem to Katy
Perry and I was like well who's putting
you up to this he goes well I really
like her I didn't go well you know I
mean maybe he's got a campaign do you
want to read your love poem now cuz I
don't know if I'll have time later this
is the part of the show where I go all
over the place
you want to do your thing since Ronnie
started writing poetry right yeah I'm
called on that singer what was it called
no uh - Katie - Katie yeah all right
okay like poetic justice just think it
would help to date Katy Perry would be
very Merry she is as sweet as a tart and
has taken a place in my heart all right
her smile is bright her body so tight
her eyes are like diamonds seeing her
laughs makes me delighted she dresses so
fine I love to have her as mine so Katy
Perry let's go out on a date I promise
not to be late and who knows maybe it's
our fate - Katy douche it was
embarrassing she heard about what you
were you know what you're saying uh yeah
she wrote a song to respond I can't wait
[Music]
there you go
now you get your answer now you can move
on to your next cut quite a dog's cave
you know I will not be dissuaded thank
you serious nice poem